bien bonjour à tous alors tout d'abord
pour ne rien vous cacher la préparation
de cette présentation a rapidement mis
dans le thème la pression je la ressens
comme tout le monde le pouls qui
s'accélère on a un peu plus de mal à
réfléchir on se sent contraint et chacun
réagit à sa façon et chacun a ses
petites solutions yoga fusion de
verveine putching ball moi il m'arrive
d'aller courir de méditer ou jouer de la
guitare
mais au delà de ça ce qui est important
pour moi c'est de garder à l'esprit les
raisons qui me poussent à mettre dans
ces conditions am infliger ça c'est un
écran noir
voilà ça commence toujours par un
engagement
il ya trois mois je me suis engagé
auprès de manon une des organisatrices
de l'événement pour participer astérix
j'ai donné ma parole à partir de ce
moment là ya pas de marche arrière alors
pourquoi je fais ça au moins un
engagement c'est comme un saut vers
l'inconnu
j'en connais rarement l'issue je me
demande pas si j'en suis capable
je réfléchis pas aux difficultés qu'il
va falloir surmonter si je le fais c'est
parce que j'ai toujours rêvé de faire un
tedx et c'est cette idée qui m'attirait
les le départ alors quand j'étais en
stress devant ma page blanche et qu'il a
fallu six mètres j'ai laissé la guitare
de côté et je me suis imaginé devant
vous en train de m'exprimer sur scène sa
part toujours d'une envie d'une volonté
d'un rêve
la même manière il ya six mois on
parlait de concert on m'a proposé de
jouer sur scène faire un concert pour la
première fois de ma vie
devant 600 personnes alors j'ai toujours
rêvé d'être une rock star donc ni une ni
deux j'ai dit oui et il arrive toujours
ce moment généralement plus l'échéance
approche le stress qui monte et cette
question qui surgit mais pourquoi je me
suis fichu là dedans eh ben c'est pour
ça alors on va pas je suis juste ici
j'avais un trac incommensurable au
moment de monter sur scène
la sensation de tout avoir oublié la
seconde où j'arrivais sur scène mais on
était bien préparés et ça reste quand
même la clé à chaque fois et on a assuré
et quand je regarde en arrière et que je
vois cette étape de franchie
j'éprouve un sentiment d'accomplissement
qui justifie absolument tous les états
de stress par lesquels j'ai pu passer et
c'est sur la base de sur ces principes
là que je me suis lancé il ya six ans
dans l'entrepreneuriat sur la base d'un
engagement
on arrive à en école donc ici j'ai
rencontré mon associé antoine lui est un
fervent roboticiens passionné par les
nouvelles technologies
moi j'étais je suis encore omnubilé par
le médical par l'homme on a eu alors
cette volonté commune de mettre la
technologie au service de l'homme pour
éradiquer le mal de dos et du coup c'est
sur la base de cette conviction commune
que la technologie pouvait apporter une
solution différenciante à cette
pathologie qu'on s'est engagé l'un
envers l'autre et c'est ainsi qu'est né
il y a 6 ans du fruit de notre réunion
japon est le premier exosquelette au
monde pour le traitement du mal de dos
et alors on dit souvent qu'une
association c'est comme un mariage c'est
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
je peux vous dire que le pire arrive
régulièrement il ya des moments durs
il ya des moments tendus on souvent des
problèmes est généralement dernières
minutes sinon c'est pas drôle
et dans ces cas faut pas seulement être
engagée faut avoir les mêmes convictions
faut avoir la même détermination que son
associé parce que c'est ça au fond qui
finit toujours par orienter les
décisions qui permet de passer au
travers des crises et surtout pas
flanché sous la pression l'essentiel ça
a toujours été pour nous de garder à
l'esprit notre objectif pourquoi on fait
ça pour éradiquer le mal de dos et c'est
ce qu'on a fait aux différents tournants
de la boîte on se concentre en non pas
sur la montagne à franchir mais sur des
objectifs intermédiaires
quand on est parti en chine par exemple
on s'était expatrié pendant quatre mois
pour accélérer le développement notre
exosquelette avec à la clé un passage au
cs la plus grande messe technologiques
du monde pourrait présenter au monde
notre exosquelette on était parti avec
amélie sur la photo designer en charge
du design de l'exosquelette qui est
devenu par la suite directrice générale
à nos côtés on a passé quatre mois à
travailler littéralement nuitées jour en
prenant 1 2 jours de repos par mois
pour aboutir à un beau produit un
produit présentable un produit dont on
serait fier le produit qu'on avait déjà
passé deux ans à imaginer alors autant
vous dire qu'on a tous fini en surmenage
on s'est chamaillé une paire de fois
durant cette période on avait beaucoup
rire méditer au fond les seules choses
qui nous faisait tenir c'était cette
détermination de montrer au monde notre
exosquelette et tout est rentré dans
l'ordre quand on est abouti à ce
dispositif qu'on avait tous eu en tête
mais la morale qu'on a conservé de ce
passage en chine tout cas moi
personnellement c'est qu'il est
important même dans les plus gros moment
de roche de s'accorder des moments de
repos et on a finalement été présenté
aux 6es le premier exosquelette pour le
traitement du mal de dos là encore c'est
difficile de retranscrire le sentiment
d'accomplissement que j'ai pu éprouver à
ce moment là quelque chose de vraiment
ufo raison j'ai directement oublier les
quatre mois que j'avais passé la tête
sous l'eau pour me reconcentrer sur les
étapes à venir alors les premiers
retours qu'on a eus était plutôt mitigé
puisqu'on nous a suggéré de faire un
dispositif qui protège les vêtements des
tâches antoine ayant malencontreusement
mal bu son café 10 secondes avant de
monter sur scène
mais par la suite ce sont les forces
spéciales américaines qui nous ont
contactés pour voir si notre dispositif
pouvait aider les soldats du coup été
jusqu'en floride pour leur présenter et
je pense que s'il avait fallu aller sur
mars pour présenter notre dispositif on
aurait été sur mars
donc on a eu une belle couverture
médiatique dans cette veine on a pu
gagner une petite notoriété et du coup
aller chercher des premiers financements
qui ont permis d'accélérer le
développement de l'entreprise
et puis il ya eu ce mail ce mail qui
nous a remis face à la réalité
face à l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés au
départ en finir avec le mal de dos ce
mail si une patiente qui nous l'a écrit
une personne qui souffre au quotidien et
qui placent clairement désespoir dans
notre dispositif des mails comme ça on
en a reçu des centaines de partout alors
là dans ma tête je réalise qu'on a
attendu au tournant que j'ai pas le
droit à l'erreur
on réalise aussi antoine amélie et moi
que à 3 on n'y arrivera pas ça fait trop
de pression pour trois bonhommes
heureusement les choses sont bien faites
et cette petite notoriété permet de
rallier à nous des gens qui partagent
les mêmes convictions qui sont prêts à
s'engager avec nous et à partager notre
objectif dès ce moment là la pression on
la partage
on la partage en rendrons la partager en
rendant tout le monde responsable en
rendant tout le monde
autonome en prenant le temps d'expliquer
à chaque fois en quoi ce qu'on fait au
quotidien s'inscrit dans notre objectif
de long terme en finir avec le mal de
dos à la différence de la chine les
états ont suivi l ont pas durer quatre
mois
elles ont duré un an j'ai d'abord eu la
mise sur le marché du dispositif on
parle d'un dispositif médical
on est sur un des marchés les plus
réglementées qui soit pour mettre ce
dispositif sur le marché il a fallu
passer près d'une dizaine d'audit près
d'autant de tests en laboratoire
certifiant un prof m'a donné une image
d'une foi qui reste est une start up ou
une jeune entreprise c'est comme une
foreuse avec suffisamment d'essence pour
percer un seul trou soit tu trouve le
pétrole soit tu meurs tu as pas assez
d'essence pour creuser une deuxième fois
je suis exactement cette situation
si on rate ce mas ce passage ses neuf
mois qu'on se prend de retard dans la
figure neuf mois à revoir l'ingénierie
du dispositif neuf mois à repasser les
tests en laboratoire
neuf mois un repas c'est les audits neuf
mois à brûler de l'argent c'est la mort
de la boîte on n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur
cette année c'était la mise en
production on a des financements qui
sont limitées si on commence pas générer
du revenu on est mort si on fait une
erreur pour vendre faut produire et si
on fait une erreur en production c'est
tous les dispositifs qui sont sur la
photo qui partent à la poubelle
donc là encore on n'a pas droit à
l'erreur et dans ces situations là je me
retrouve dans cette image savoir il ya
un choix qui s'offre à moi et c'est ma
responsabilité je suis le seul à pouvoir
l'assumer choix là donc la pression la
partage mais pas toujours
je ne partage pas avec l'équipe cette
pression là s'il ya une erreur c'est mon
erreur c'est moi qu'ils assument auprès
de mon associé auprès des investisseurs
alors on parle souvent de la solitude de
l'entrepreneur c'est parce qu'on peut
pas tout partager avec tout le monde
dans la boîte c'est là qu'il est
important d'échanger avec d'autres
entrepreneurs d'autres chefs
d'entreprises qui sont passés par les
mêmes déboires que moi et qui je peux
parler librement relâcher la pression en
relativisant et j'aimerais finir sur
cette photo c'est une photo de l'équipe
qu'on a emmené l'année dernière en haut
d'un pic de 4 mm
on a monté tous ensemble cette équipe
qui partagent les mêmes convictions -
cette équipe que je vois tous les jours
et qui me rappellent au quotidien les
engagements que j'ai pris vis-à-vis de
vis-à-vis de moi-même
des noms associés il est des
investisseurs vis-à-vis des patients
cette équipe qui fait preuve de la même
détermination dans les bons moments et
dans les moins bons moments pour en
finir avec le mal de dos alors comme je
disais au départ la pression tout le
monde là elle est omniprésente mais
posez vous les bonnes questions
parce que ce qui est important c'est de
garder à l'esprit les raisons qui nous
ont poussés à nous mettre dans ces
situations je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]